Hello world.
It's the Raj and there are so many
different neural architectures that I feel
like I could just talk about them all
day on Youtube. Dreams do come true.
An auto encoder is a neural network
that's not just really useful for a lot of
tasks.
It's also an easy entry point to learn
more complex concepts in machine learning.
Let's go over some theory and code in
order to grasp this model capable of
everything from image colorization
to dialogue generation fully.
If we've got data that's properly
labeled B that images or audio or text,
we're in luck. Deep learning works
really well with labeled datasets.
That's because there is always a
function that represents the relationship
between both columns.
It's easy to conceptualize
this if our dataset is numeric,
like if our input data was a bunch of
numbers and the labels defined whether or
not that input data was an
even number or an odd number,
the function that represents the
relationship between these two columns is
simple. If the input data is divisible
by two, the number is even Ellis.
It's odd.
All data types be that video or text can
be represented numerically and as such,
there is always a function
that maps the relationship.
It's just a more complex function
than the one we just discussed.
So while it's kind of incredible that
we can speak to our computers now and
they're able to transcribe
what we are saying be,
that's Siri or Alexa or Google now.
Okay Google,
do you love me? Ha ha ha ha. No.
Speech recognition is just the result
of deep learning on labeled datasets.
If a team of developers is trying to
create a speech recognition engine,
they use a Dataset of audio clips
with their transcripts as the labels.
Every single bite of the audio can be
broken down into a series of numbers and
so can the text transcripts.
Some combination of operations will
convert the input to the labels and that
combination is the function.
Neural networks can slowly approximate
or get closer and closer to this function
through an iterative optimization
process. Also called training. In short,
it's minimizing an error value at every
iteration so that given a novel audio
clip, it can easily predict what
the transcript for it would be.
Deep learning is essentially
performing a to B mappings. That's it.
A more accurate way to say this is
that it's performing universal function
approximation,
meaning with sufficient data it can
approximate any function input alone
application output, the likelihood
a customer, we'll repay it,
input an email and I'll put the
possibility it's spam or not.
Spam input usage patterns
for a fleet of cars,
an output where to send a car next
like the dumpster if it was made by GM.
Since there are an endless
array of applications for this,
deep learning has gotten really popular,
but while deep learning is good at
finding a function we don't already know,
but have training data for it,
surprisingly useful to find a function
we already know and then look at how we
found it. All neural networks
are composite functions.
That means they are functions of
functions. The more layers a network has,
the more nested functions it
has for a three layer network.
We'd multiply the input by
the first weight matrix,
apply an activation function to it and
repeat the process. Once again, this time,
using the output as our
new input input times wait,
activates the result is our output.
This can be represented as a composite
function since we're using the output of
the first function as
input to the next function.
But let's say our goal
wasn't to find a label. Why,
but instead to reconstruct
the original input x,
meaning if our input was an array
consisting of a few numbers,
our network should output that same
input with those same exact numbers.
After applying the series
of operations to it,
we can call the first part of the network
that compresses the input into fewer
bits.
The encoder,
and we can call the second part that
reconstructs the image that decode is.
So why should we care about doing this?
Well, we don't care about the output.
It's just a replica of the input.
What we care about is the hidden layer.
Once a network can reliably
reconstruct its input,
the hidden layer must contain enough
information to represent the output.
If as is typical, the hidden layer is
smaller than the input and output layers.
What it represents is the same
information in a lower density.
It's a much more dense
representation of the input data.
One that is learned over time,
although it turns out that there are
better techniques for data compression.
Auto encoders are still really useful
for some tasks like dimensionality
reduction.
Once we have a more condensed
representation of some
multidimensional data,
we can easily visualize it and just two
or three dimensions for further analysis.
We can also use it for classification.
The idea is that we trained an autoencoder
to reconstruct its instances of a
particular class. We don't train it
on any instances of any other class.
Then to classify new instances,
we feed them to the auto
encoder at the input layer,
get a reconstruction in the output layer
and compute the reconstruction error,
which is usually a measure of distance
between the reconstruction and the input.
If it generalizes to a new instance
and reconstructs it properly,
then it's likely to be of the same class
as the incidence it used to train on.
Anomaly detection is another use case.
We first trained it on normal instances
so that if we feed it any anomalies,
there'll be detected easily.
If we train it to recognize anomaly
instances in our training set,
it would only find the ones
that look like anomalies.
It's already seen in many cases.
We have very few anomalies
in our training that set,
but when using an auto encoder,
this isn't a problem.
So auto encoders are just neural networks
where the target output is the input.
We don't actually need any new code.
If we're just using a super simple
psychic learn like interface.
We'd simply train our model by
changing a single parameter.
Instead of model dot bit x and Y,
we just say model.fit x and x.
All the usual training strategies
work with auto encoders including
backpropagation and
regularization and drop out.
It's fun to take an existing neural
network library and see what kind of low
dimensional representations
we can come up with.
If we were to build a really
simple autoencoder using
the care os deep learning
library to reconstruct a
training set of images.
Notice how a single fully connected
neuro layer acts as the encoder and as a
decoder, and this model is
just a simple neural network.
We're only calling it an auto encoder
because we're feeding it the input data as
the labels.
Since we don't have any labels,
the reconstructed results will look
very similar to the original input data.
After we're done training,
sometimes though the model could overfit
on the input data and in order for it
to be able to learn a better, more
robust representation to the input data,
we can manually add some noise and this
is called a de noising auto encoder.
The amount of noise to apply to the input
usually takes the form of a percentage.
There are so many different types
of auto encoders we could make,
but one in particular that I really like
is called the variational autoencoder.
This learns a latent variable
model of its input data.
Instead of letting the
network learn some function,
we're learning the parameters
of a probability distribution
that models our data.
Then we can sample points from this
distribution and generate new input data
samples meaning a Vav can be
considered a generative model.
This lets us create all sorts of new
images and videos that have never existed
before. Image colorization, chatbots,
VA ease are right up there with generative
adversarial networks as one of my top
five favorite deep learning models.
Three points to encode in your biological
neural network. From this video,
neural networks can slowly approximate
any function that maps inputs to outputs
through an iterative optimization process.
Also called training.
If we set the output to
be the same as the input,
we can call this neural network and auto
encoder because it encodes a more dense
representation of the input data and
there are many types of auto encoders we
could make.
A more recent generative model is
called the variational auto encoder,
which learns a latent
variable of its input data.
This week's coding challenge is to create
a simple auto encoder using the care
os deep learning library.
Post your get hub link in the comments
section and the winners will be announced
in one week. Please subscribe for
more programming videos. And for now,
I've got to solve AI or die trying.
So thanks for watching.